the jurogan experience so then covet
starts
somebody sends me an article from the
new york times about ayahuasca
and i'm like
and he's like we gotta do this i'm like
all right
i get a number
get a private i had to go off
antidepressants this is october 2020.
so i go i wean myself off i'm taking
zoloft all the time
and i'm like why am i taking so i'm like
i don't need it frank because the
problem was without zoloft i wasn't
depressed but i was getting panic
attacks on stage
which is like this i can't have this so
i just takes all off like and i wouldn't
get panic attacks
uh only on stage yeah i and one time i
got one like in a meeting it was [ __ ]
weird or i'm like i i know this person
it was odd i would just get them for
seemingly no reason
and um and so
go off antidepressants
do ayahuasca with like uh with one
uh shaman type guy
at my buddy's house and it's like
very pleasant it was like we did one cup
it was me bianca from the store
uh my friend bijan saramello like
uh and it was like nice right
um it kind of felt like
i like cried about groups of people
groups of people i don't know just like
gatherings of people made me cry huh
like i was crying so hard like like
where like my your nostrils are closed
like is it unusual that you experience
the kind of sadness that makes you it
wasn't even sadness it was like kind of
tears of like
joy reverie not joy and not like
tenderness
we'll say like tenderness about like
like a from a place of love okay more
than a place of sadness or
it was like just connected yeah yeah i
feel connected to like the
earth i was getting like also seeing
like wide shots of forests
ooh just like okay cool
so we and then you know lasts about
three and a half hours then we all hang
out talk whatever
and then i find a better that guy was
kind of a lightweight and then i find a
better
circle to do it in
via uh someone that had been on a
commercial she was like come to the
circle
so i
first night at the circle
it's like by six flags in la it's not
like it's not peru
um and uh it's i couldn't get the amount
right
and i was just kind of nauseous and
didn't really feel much
and i did ayahuasca did two or three
cups of ayahuasca i tried this thing
called hoppe
which is they blows
ash
sacred tobacco ash up your nostrils
and it's like you have [ __ ] rocks in
your head i've never felt a thing like
this and apparently it like multiplies
the ayahuasca for like eight to ten
minutes it's like a [ __ ] mushroom and
and super mario brothers very like just
it's you're like oh stimulated and
people you can do a thing where you do
an intention and a lot of times you'll
vomit up
you'll purge up a thing like a notion
i have a
yeah i got a lot of a lot of stories so
the ash the ash if you look it's spelled
r-a-p-e with an uh with an um lot over
the e so it's spelled rate but it's with
an umlaut over the e and people blo it's
a in a thing called a tepe
and uh
so that's just smoke but there you go
that's
one the first one
that now that's smoke if you
do uh get rid of ayahuasca and smoke
just do
[Music]
put a um lot over the uh e
in yeah the problem is rape crisis it
just goes yeah if you put it if you put
a thing over the e how do you do that on
a regular keyboard you just add the e
you hit option and then hit
hit e and i'm just going to come up here
can you google
yeah there we go
let's see okay
okay there he goes there oh wow that's
wild that looks painful it's
wild look at the face
yeah i tried that and so the ash goes up
your nose yeah and and you're like
like it i didn't i was just like yo this
[ __ ] people purge immediately
but you a lot of times you can purge up
like an ocean
you can purge up an intention you can
purge up i mean a buddy of mine purged
up his mother's hatred of him oh jesus
like like
a thing i'm a like i'm basically like a
goof i'm like a new age goofball is what
i'm trying to tell you
uh so that's the first night with the
it's my second
career night thir
first night at the new circle
second night i get the amount correct
and i
was an atheist
and i
opened my eyes
at one point in the circle and i was
like oh i'm in the presence of god right
now
i don't i can't explain it it's a
feeling
i am in the presence of
what i can only describe as god and i
was like this is the first spiritual
experience i've ever had in my entire
life 12 years of catholic school altar
boy church mass [ __ ]
nothing and then this was like oh
this is what church is supposed to be
like this connection to
us the center beam or the center force
and uh
like a real profound
like okay i'm no longer an atheist
i now believe in a
a
uh
god or
creation force
and obviously the question would be
someone ask you if they were trying to
diminish this they would say but you are
on drugs yeah you understand that you're
on drugs and this is not a real
experience and this is all highlighted
by the hallucination that's happening in
the neurotransmitters and the way it's
affecting your brain
yeah i don't i here's the thing i can't
counter that do you know what i mean
like i'm not it's not one of these
things where like it's true for me right
well here's the question here's here's
what i always say is i have this very
same conversation with dennis mckenna
and we both agreed on this that who
cares if it's real it's the same
experience like if if you took a pill
and that pill or you took ayahuasca and
that ayahuasca makes you reach that
state or if you reach that state from
saying an incantation and then you walk
through holotropic breathing yeah
whatever it is yeah how do we know that
that's not real like imagine if god was
real and you could get in front of god
but the only way to do it is to eat
mushrooms he'd be like wait what i would
argue that's true it might be
it's the only way now the the good thing
is
it's in me now
because it then i was no longer in
ayahuasca and i was like that was as
real a thing as ever happened it's in
you meaning it's changed you
yeah
so the depression's gone well that i'll
get to that so no no my belief in god
yes a belief in a central creation force
right and by the way i know how this
sounds it's very mockable it's very
reducible and like this podcast is
filled with mockable reductions sure
sure sure um laughing all the way to the
bank
um and uh mocking getting mocked all the
way uh so
so the
fourth time i do it the that circle
that i was doing in they weren't like
covered they were like loose with covid
and it's like 20 people in a room and
this is in like before the vaccine it's
just like early so i'm like ah a guy got
covered
right after the ceremony i'm like could
you test or anything like we don't
really just whatever
um so i went back to the first guy the
the original guy
and did a private with ian edwards
and
my friend catherine and
uh worked for ian
he had a great time
not great time but like a profound
spiritual time my friend catherine was
sort of like very uneasy
and then and i it wasn't working for me
and i kept saying yeah it just wasn't
working i was like maybe i'll take more
cause like it felt like i had to work
out the amount at the other place so
this place was like maybe i'll take more
and i probably ended up drinking like an
ounce and i don't
i've come to drink around a quarter of
an ounce but so this was like an ounce
and
it wasn't working wasn't working wasn't
working
hit me like
a [ __ ] freight train where like i
immediately i purged
and um
i
i uh went into like i would have a
thought like what
and my brain and in my brain it sounded
like i'd go what it would go i i i i i
and i was like oh i'm in pink floyd land
like i'm law i'm gone
i'm going to be a drug casualty
uh
then i was
in outer space
uh alone
and the universe was dying
you're alone
we're killing saturn
children
uh
the milky way like
that was the message i was getting like
it's all dying and you're alone and i
breathed
i mean it's the most terrifying thing
i've ever experienced until i'll get to
the thing that topped it
uh
i was breathing
just in case
i was literally like breathing ian said
i was breathing like this
and i was for like he said about two and
a half hours
i have no recollection of any of it
other than
i'm in outer space
like
it it's
i was when i came to
i was
i slept with the lights on
for a few days
it was so terrifying to my absolute
core
um
and i but i realized
about three or four days after
that
from not being on antidepressants the
i'd say the floorboards of my mood were
a little mushy
like the like i could get low
lower than i could
without antidepressants
i'm sorry with antidepressants it would
be like more sort of secure
and
not on antidepressants it was a little
loose and gushy
and i realized about four days after
that terrifying outer space experience
that it was
completely secure
and it was like polished
granite like it fixed your brain yeah
like i'm never gonna and i literally was
like i'm never gonna need
antidepressants again
positive
and you haven't had them since no really
yeah that was like that was in december
2020. that's incredible yeah yeah and
here we are it's the end of may
yeah so this is a year and a half 2022.
so uh incredible yeah i had a little
panic on stage but i figured that out so
so that was so so now so i've done i
have four times at this point had that
experience and i was like i really like
aya in that it's it's it's a connection
to spirituality you know what i mean
like you know in in
i don't have any besides that you know
and
so i went to the other place the good
circle
and
i had a few rough ceremonies
um
like
one of them
in the room
i heard
a
uh
tiger like
like
it's in the room
there is a tiger in the room
acoustically it was like there was a
tiger in the room and then i
hallucinated a tiger came around an
altar and i went like
like real [ __ ]
fear
and i had a couple tough journeys like
that where it was one another one that
was funnier is i thought
i mean dude in this circle i've seen
people get
they
possessed
to tie a guy up
like it's
it's impossible but i've seen it it's
one of these things where i'm like ah
this shit's wild
um
that one where the guy was possessed
they had to pour salt in his mouth like
real wild [ __ ] um
i'm like oh this is the rapture this is
the rapture when the rapture
this is the end like we're and so i had
that like rapture thing again
and they go let's go around the room
just check in with everybody neil and i
go not good
like two couple words to describe you
feel like oh not good and then they go
to the next guy and he goes i'm
balancing and i'm like balancing
dawg this is it
like it's over and then when i heard
balancing and i and then as they went on
i was like oh this is not the rapture i
was like neil this is your problem and
your problem alone